tu carro puede recorrer 25 millas por
galón por galón y quieres hacer un viaje
de 400 millas 400 millas muy bien justo
ahora la gasolina cuesta 30 pesos vamos
a marcarlo en color rosa 30 pesos por
galón por galón y la pregunta es cuánto
te va a costar costar es en pesos cuando
te va a costar la gasolina para el viaje
muy bien entonces aquí nos dan algunas
tasas de conversión entre entre galones
millas y peso si queremos determinar al
final un costo lo primero que yo haría
en este contexto es ver cuántos galones
necesito vale entonces lo que nos dicen
es que el viaje es de 400 millas déjame
hacer el 4 un poco más bonito 400 millas
millas millas
sale entonces lo primero que haría sería
pasar esto a galones es decir ver
cuántos galones voy a gastar al recorrer
estas 400 millas y para eso necesito
usar algunas de estas dos tazas la de
abajo relación a pesos por hong kong
galón así que esa no me sirve
usar la de arriba y nos dice que el
carro puede recorrer 25 millas por galón
déjame poner aquí las unidades que nos
interesan aquí necesitamos millas para
que se cancelen y arriba nos quede
galones entonces aquí arriba es galón
galones o le voy a poner galones vale y
ahora si vamos a usar esta tasa nos dice
que recorre 25 millas por galón sale
entonces las millas van abajo son 25
millas por cada galón por cada galón
simplemente tomé esta razón que nos dan
aquí y le saqué el recíproco para
obtener la tasa entre galones y millas
bueno vamos a ver cuánto es eso las
millas se cancelan con millas entonces
las unidades son galones galones galones
y nos queda 400 entre 25 el número 400
entre 25 es 16 entonces sería 16
y 6 galones y aquí es bueno ver que todo
concuerde con la realidad si tiene
sentido que 16 galones recorran 400
millas pues sí sobre todo si has
manejado a lo mejor te has dado cuenta
que con cierta cantidad de litros o
galones se recorren muchas millas o
kilómetros entonces esto tiene sentido
en la vida real y no sólo eso sino que
también tiene sentido matemático verdad
si se recorren 25 millas por galón
entonces se necesitan menos galones que
millas o bueno se gastan menos galones
de las millas que se recorren bueno pero
ya tenemos estos 400 millas gastan 16
galones pero aún no hemos respondido la
pregunta que nos hacen que tiene que ver
con un costo estos 16 galones que voy a
poner aquí 16 galones galones todavía
tenemos que pasarlos a pesos entonces
tenemos que hacer una taza en la cual
los galones se cancelen le voy a poner
aquí galones y arriba aparezcan pesos
aquí voy a poner
pesos
muy bien entonces cuál es esta tasa pues
esta tasa que nos dan aquí la gasolina
cuesta 30 pesos 30 pesos por galón y
tiene todo el sentido del mundo verdad
este de aquí es el precio unitario es el
precio unitario de cada galón de
gasolina entonces si multiplicamos jaja
si multiplicamos el precio unitario por
la cantidad de galones que compramos
entonces eso nos daría el costo total
vale bueno vamos a hacer las operaciones
esto de aquí sería igual a los galones
se cancelan con galones y tendríamos que
hacer 16 por 30 para que nos dé la
cantidad total de pesos 16 por tres es
48 por 10 es 480 entonces nos queda 480
pesos pesos y por lo tanto utilizando tu
carro para recorrer esta distancia de
400 millas se van a gastar 480 pesos